very
common like you don't understand the
angles that you're trying to do on the
body you just do some footwork it's not
really an angle change here if you pay
attention do you see what I mean like
you can still turn and hit me you see
what I'm trying to do is hide hide over
here you see your shoulder is way over
there you get it we go like this and
then look your shoulder is not way over
there so my my angle can be very small
can be very small I'm in it you see I
got in it again and maybe the camera
needs to go here and hid it
out it's not it's not in that you just
step out that way you're looking for
angles okay
so likewise I need an angle for my entry
okay if I'm going to do a Mot I need a
particular opening for the entry if I'm
going to do Ura I need a different
opening so I can't do the same
shikaku over here I'm not going to get a
m this this elbow's way on that side
okay so I have to want to do a mul look
you see I put that elbow on this side of
me so it's easy for me to get on the
back side with one entry you
see Margaret
say but
likewise okay if I if you're over here
like this and now I enter you're too far
forward now I have to pull you
back and that's not
it so although my hand is doing the same
thing and I'm still on that angle I'm
going to move you in a
way that it'll
work so I'm going to give you a
reference a Mor is going to take your
whole body and move
it as if I'm throwing you
away or this takes the front of your
body the front of your body only the
front you see then I can get
behind doing the same
thing is eventually going to be in the
wrong place then it's the wrong
thing so you have you have an external
solution to what I did okay so you come
over here and you push the core okay and
then you now I can't get to ur unless I
move your arm where I would have wanted
it in the first place so you see that so
you go you go here why don't you step
and then I won't have to push you okay
so
's close stay there I'm supposed to be
here but I'm not so what you do is you
now grab the arm and now you moved it to
where it is you see that that's
external so uh when I come
around instead of pushing into your core
like that you see I push into your core
I just touch this surface
here this part just this part okay and
look where you're going to
go you see there we
go just the just the surface
around
surface there
okay not everything is pushed through
okay try it
again so um I have a yyong
theory okay and by that theory all
things are
categorized Yin or Y and I also know
that within every Yin there's some y
just my theory okay all things
are categorized in
that dichotomy but that dichotomy is
relative okay it's Yin Yong to varying
degrees but it is Yin or
yangong from a particular perspective
every always
okay so I have an inward spiral and I
have an out spiral but that does not
mean
that I do my hand the same way every
time through
space is that's not how it works so just
as something is always Yin or
Yong and something always yin yangong to
varying degrees how much yin to how much
Yong do you see that all things are
that but inside is an infinite variation
potential and this same thing goes with
my inward or my outward spiral and I
don't do the same thing every time okay
so for example okay I can project him
out with this spiral and at no point
I'll do it again okay at no point can he
come in with that spiral so even even if
he wanted to he can't come forward with
that spiral he can't come forward
okay well I can do it in resp spiral
change it shape just a little is timing
on how it's passing through this and you
see I brought him forward and over
towards my
left can do the same thing and
look he's going this
way still an inward spiral you guys get
that okay it's not that I do this and
then Uka decides what he's going to do
can't UK can't do something else UK
can't do something
else okay so like let's say he he's
trying to to pull just going to come
more in that way okay on that one over
here so I can't I I'm telling you that
Ur the K is on the surface of him
you can't do the same inward spiral that
keeps him out and trying to be on the
surface with less penetration it doesn't
work you have to
change which inward spiral you do
okay meaning you have to change its
yinong values okay they're not
constant so the reason I do this is as
we already
mentioned I don't want to do an external
thing one there's no energetics to it
two grab hard I can't pull that off I
cannot pull that off it's not Marshall
okay and I don't want to use that outer
delto so when I go inside only on the
surface you can see that I'm moving I
can now enter around it push out of the
grip just like a m
does and then under the same
technique without using the outer
delto it's hand
just
falls into my other
hand okay